having a couple of these examples ah
okay
I don't think keep cases is absolutely
devastatingly bad it's it's one of the
name options we have is a subsection
there with a couple of other ones we
looked at
um yeah we don't like openings yeah sift
was another one I kind of thought of it
might be a little esoteric and
filter would work but we have lots of
filters oh no yeah
um
let me see
uh
Civ
that's a bit obscure
absolutely not Civ
number Theory connotations
I I said sift but yes yeah yeah shift is
I'm okay with
[Music]
yeah my only concern with keep cases is
that as soon as we call it cases we
start thinking about patterns
um
which doesn't delete cases support the
list structure too
I mean
okay if I simply say here
cases
three cases takes a pattern right so
you'd have to do Alternatives at yeah
yep so in this case the same result the
same results
it would not be if you want to preserve
the positional cases that didn't match
which was where the idea originally came
from was you know this is
in some ways a filtering way to preserve
the structure of the data
whereas you know cases is inherently
going to give you back a list
a flat list
um
right
the problem with prune is it's the wrong
way around right
um
okay what is this doing what is the
why not keep elements because you have
delete elements
that also takes a list of but it doesn't
accept a level
so to leak
uh
maybe it makes sense to extend delete
elements with the level and also
keep elements kind of would work the
same way so there would be
well this is removes all elements
but one could give it
a thing to put in that place I suppose I
don't know why I want to do that because
one industry is replaced for that
uh but but is the first argument being a
list more restrictive than the first
argument being a general expression
there
maybe so
but
look I agree keep elements is reasonable
in the sense that it
matches syntactically what we were
talking about
well it doesn't seem bad actually I mean
this funky syntax with
and instances one could even support
here
keep only up to that number of instances
of each of these things
see what I'm saying yeah yeah I can't
think of an immediate use case for it
but we could certainly support it
I can imagine once but
I think this is a reasonable name
um now in terms of the level spec
um what does it do it the multi-level
case I mean the multi-level case is
tricky because you know if you if you
take the the toy implementation I have
here and you put in level two it's just
gonna flatten it down
to just two elements in in this
particular input or I guess three
elements sorry I'm sorry if you do what
here so the the first line I have there
is a toy implementation uh of prune
and if you change it from
uh in that Matrix form example if you
remove the braces around the two it'll
be a multi-level spec and it'll just
flatten the whole thing down to three
missings
I'm totally confused it's because it
because it looks up because it's like
map it looks at the higher levels right
it looks at the higher levels first and
says Ah these darns in the list of
expected what the level spec is supposed
to be right so if you were going to do
this with a level spec
is there a point in doing it with a
level speckle can you just map this
thing over the thing and get the same
results
uh I mean you should be able to map it
yeah you could map at minimally but yeah
well I mean why do you have to map out
why isn't this just a map whatever you
can do with level spec here you can do
the map yeah that's true okay I don't
think we should have a level spec
I think it's confusing as you say
because it could it could smoosh the it
could
blow the thing up at a higher level
and then it like this looks good so
let's do it yeah one spin-off question
then is delete elements currently is set
up for lists I believe I don't believe
it works on arbitrary Expressions we
could potentially extend it to or if we
wanted to do that with keep elements or
we could just say
developments and delete elements only
work on X lists
oh actually delete elements does work on
arbitrary expressions
it just wasn't yeah
I kind of thought it did
yeah I mean the list case is certainly
the same yes the object can have any
that had not necessarily list yep
okay okay easy enough then
all right let's go on merge and keys
so this was a suggestion that Brad had
um and I can have him talk up about it a
little more but looking to get some more
information about how
about the keys during messaging and
whether this is something that could be
generalized yeah and you know I was
thinking about it a little more today
um if the keys themselves contain some
important information
then when you're doing the merge you
could also be switching on Keys exactly
how you do the merge
yes but what what does merge normally
take
it's just the values
using the function to combine values
well why isn't this a supplied play
yeah that would be kind of a natural
place to have it there because I mean
there are all kinds of weird things like
the position in the association index
yeah right there are all kinds of things
you might want
uh I I think the positions in the
association it would be a little bit
lower down the priority list yeah I
understand we what are we going to do we
can't change merge to have that function
take more than one arguments
so what are we going to do we have to
have a thing which basically specifies
some kind of Handler keys or something
[Music]
yeah I guess I hadn't thought about the
the intersection of supplied and
messaging but it would be a nice way to
effectively have that meta information
available yep
okay yeah I will pass that along to
etai for the next discussion on Supply
just as a use case
fine
you know the fact that we keep on
calling this thing supplied even though
it's had many other names is a sign
yeah I think it's pretty intuitive what
it means when we call it supplied
right
what were the other names we had for
which we don't remember anymore
we had including
there's some variation of includes
um
okay well maybe some others but we
should get back sorry for my ignorance
here but how does how is supplied a
workaround for this thing about missing
keys
because
supplied is a way of specifying
look the idea is that you say map
supplied
f
comma and then this can tell you you
know the index the value
and this is then supplying to f
both index and value
whereas normally without the supplied F
just gets the value get what I'm saying
um and I guess key could be in there too
yeah exactly so I mean for example or
Keys plural or whatever we can have
named the whole point is that in a given
situation like map for example that you
can put a supplied there which has a
certain known collection of possible
values that it can fishes out of the map
environment
get what I'm saying so here in this case
with merge we would say this blah blah
blah comma supplied and then the
comparator
let's go what I'm saying so you could
just say supplied of this
right okay I think what I'm getting here
is that it puts more power into the
user's hands about having extra
arguments and then how to order them
yeah
you add like meta information to the
event from the environment it's
information from the environment in this
case information from the merge in the
case of map information from the map
like
yeah
you know what was the depth for example
of this at which this this F you know is
is occurring let's say this map had been
a map all
right it would have different depth
information Etc et cetera et cetera it's
like supplying environmental matter
information
into a function application
and as to your question Stephen I think
supplied is next up on the list for LCC
there's just been some scheduling
conflicts that have kept us from getting
all the important parties together
okay
so we had started talking about this
last time also the idea of modernizing
reap or having a variant of reap that
allows us to create an association
um
the main sticking points being you know
basically we'd have a result key and
then we would have the different
elements that have been sewn with their
Associated tags
you know the
the single argument form of
reap we'll grab all of the The Zone keys
but you don't necessarily know what
order they're going to be in but the
sticking point we ran into is what would
we call the UN labeled or the untagged
Zone elements so anything can be a tag
that is actually documented as none
um
hey I understand that but the problem is
if they're in an association and they're
all called none they will crush
Bill merge
I'm saying well actually no I I see I
see what you're saying is
this is the list of all things sewn with
the tag none correct
yeah so the single argument version of
so is equivalent to so of whatever with
none
um I had forgotten about that last time
we were looking at this okay fine well
then that's an answer
so then the question is you know I
don't know that there's a way to really
integrate this into reap itself
let's look at let's see what the reap
has a property option
okay let's look at these other cases
reap reaps only ones that match this
okay so that's like a key cases
um
what's this
so I believe that one basically applies
F to the tag and elements I haven't
really used that so if you made F rule
it would almost be the same as this
except it'd be a list of rules of
settlement Association
I think this could fit with a fourth
argument be an association and this will
be a pair FG like we use in distribution
and things like that
um
sorry distribute
right
that's kind of well if you had
associations of the fourth argument is
there anything that would actually work
for f
or would it have to be rule
right it's almost like you want a magic
string as the third argument that does
this
yeah otherwise I think it would have to
be pure function of slot two right
yeah something like that
well that's an argument for reap
Association
is that the right way around is that war
will be Association reap now it's reap
Association it returns an association
right yeah
or it returns a list that the second
arguments Association
depends if you want this result Zone
level
or not
well maybe reap Association I mean it
probably needs that pattern argument too
it doesn't need the F argument but it
does need the pattern argument
correct yeah yes
um
but for the F it could have a property
argument
and the
the resource function I did support that
F argument
although it was a long time ago I don't
remember exactly the behavior
well okay so one possibility is there's
a single Association
that has both the tag the sewing tags
and the results in it because I think
this two level Association is pretty
ugly
mm-hmm
the question is what's the name of the
magic I mean because the tags can be
anything right
yeah and you do need the output of the
entire evaluation sure so you do need it
something's wrapping the association
um
okay so the question is I mean we do not
want to have something where
you have a list of the outer level and
then it's an association that seems
really ugly
uh
uh I mean the third argument of reap
Association could be a property thing
that picks
what form you want this output in
uh
wait why why does repossessation doesn't
return rude await for the tagged one
for the result is it it's a new way to
rule but not for the attack
this one here or those the ones there
but the the non one
result something that I want to be
annihilated
yes I agree that's a reasonable point
but
um
okay so the way you use this is
yeah you'd say you know R equals reap
Association blah blah blah things sub
result things sub sewing
I think it's okay
this looks fairly reasonable to me I
wouldn't put enough go ahead I like
having the top level Association like
that because your evaluation might
return something like nothing or a
sequence or something like that which
would be hard to figure out a list
yes
um okay
all right so I think we've got another
winner though
okay
Association key d flat that doesn't
sound promising in terms of right yes
um
maybe descriptive but it's uh
a little wordy but there's necessary
word association needed
let's just see what it does first
I I made it as an inverse for another
resource function called Association key
flatten
or maybe I made the other one I don't
remember which one I made
what does it do
so it takes like a
it basically just creates nested
associations from a flat Association
where
your keys are just the
a list of the positions yeah so each
each element in the list in the key
is a another level of Association that's
been basically squashed in this case
yeah I understand
this is a reconstruct
Association from
it's kind of a transpose operation
except yeah
yeah it's very much like a transpose
Association
[Music]
so we have an association transpose
don't we
yes what does it do
I don't think we do oh no don't we okay
I think if it's I think if it's Square
transpose might work on an association
and general utilities we have one a
rectangular
foreign
Association transfers well maybe this is
that I mean this should be
this should be a version of that where
there's a level spec
that that is more for like if you have a
list of associations
it will give you an association where
each item is a list and vice versa
so it's
kind of a different thing and what is
this doing then I mean this is just
exchanging list keys
yeah this is more of I guess you could
call it like a key transpose
this is kind of I mean it's interesting
I just don't quite understand I mean it
reminds me of you know join across which
some people think is the most
magnificent thing in the world and most
people don't understand what it does
yeah so I I guess a use case that I
thought was interesting with this is we
already have file system map which
works on a on basically a tree-like
structure for a file Association and and
creates these sort of nested levels of
associations yep and oftentimes you get
things like file names that will be
you know if you break a file name up
into its elements you'll get lots of
matching lists that will be like this
where each element numerically in order
will correspond to a level of basically
a flattened Association file name split
a bunch of files you'll get a file
structure or you'll get an association
structure that looks a lot like this
being able to merge it back into a
single
large or deeply nested Association can
be useful I agree
um you know if that's strong enough of a
use case to have a system function I
don't entirely know
um but I've seen data like this
occasionally and and wanted to basically
squash it into a single okay here's the
deal here's the deal
there are a zillion
array and Association you know array
like list arrays Association arrays
there are a zillion of these operations
which
we kind of need this General formalism
to talk about
whether this is you know from string
diagrams to this to that there's just a
lot of array gymnastics
and I feel like we don't have a good
principled way of talking about them at
this time
you know we've had in the past a certain
number of things like flatten and
transpose and things of this kind
okay we have the option allowed heads
and that
is able to tell some of these functions
you are talking about
that associations are allowed
yeah that's pretty obscure I mean what
I'm asking is
you're trying to rearrange I don't have
a good sense and perhaps it would help
if there were graphical representations
of this
of what
you know this various array gymnastics
what they mean
and how do I how do I how would I ask
for some something like this
you get what I'm saying I mean in in um
like in the modern world of llm based
programming
you might just give an example of what
you want and it might deduce this is the
gymnastics you're trying to do
I mean in other words there's got to be
a way to do this that either you say
I understand I have a way to represent
this complicated nested you know list
Association combo thing in a way that's
some kind of diagrammatic thing and I
can say I want to turn this into that or
some kind of symbolic
you know almost type level
representation of these things I want to
turn this into that
or I literally just say I've got an
example of this I I'm gonna you know I
want it to turn into that by example
do you get what I'm saying
yeah it's sort of coercing something
into another pattern essentially right
yes
yeah I mean
and uh
um
right but the question is how to specify
that
you've got what I'm saying
yeah I know what you mean it sounds
difficult
well right but I mean I don't know
yeah I mean that that's what that's what
I'm
that's what I'm trying to understand uh
um we have a flat list of integers for
example and you specify a pattern that's
like
uh a list of
lists with you know triple underscore or
whatever so you're just defining a
pattern where it's a list of lists could
we
somehow infer that that should be
partition or something
yeah well right I mean so this would be
you just give let's imagine that the
thing that you gave
was this
that's the target pattern
yeah well that's an interesting idea I'm
not sure how much ambiguity there is and
what flows where
in other words if it is the case
that you say I have a bunch of things
and their flattened form is always going
to have all elements in the same order
and now I'm simply going to sort of uh
cluster the elements
um
in um
I think in a lot of cases this would be
something like find instance where there
isn't like a unique solution to this and
we just kind of have heuristics to
figure out a sensible thing to do
like if you didn't have underscore three
times for example in that first list and
you just had
you know blank sequence or whatever yeah
maybe we could just automatically try to
make a squarish
shaped yes yes yes yes
yeah but basically what you're saying is
I'm gonna make a picture of what I want
now try and put it in that form
yeah
I think it's interesting and I think
that that has a much higher chance of
success than to give another 18
functions
that
you know
I mean I'm not sure how complete and
whether it's necessary to even make it
that complete because as you say I mean
in this particular case here what we'd
be saying is the pattern we want is
blank arrow
oops blank arrow
Association
blank I mean maybe we don't even need to
you know whatever blank
triple blank or something pretty much
and then it's this thing here
dot dot dot
or dot dot
I think this is an interesting idea
yeah I mean one could imagine
generalizing this also to Strings and
things
well go ahead
yeah I mean it's a very
fuzzy concept and
you know I don't think we could get
things exactly right all the time but
maybe
they could make something that's useful
enough most of the time
I think this is the direction to go and
we should talk about this in connection
also with this whole string diagramming
type stuff I think
because that may be there may be an
actual type of formalism okay there are
three three related things
type their specifications
this idea of four related things okay so
what do we got we've got type
specifications
we've got llm examples
and we've got
um
uh well this pattern
pattern based structures
and then we've got sort of the um string
diagramy type stuff
graphical representations
does that make sense
yeah Essence to me
yeah
so our goal will be to bring those
together with including
um yeah no that's good
all right let's quickly look at some of
these others
oh my gosh
yeah it's sort of interesting
is this also related to uh forget what
we're going to call it uh co-map
yeah it's somewhat similar to combat
um where you're basically applying a
list of functions to an expression
in this case we're we're getting the
keys or
maintaining the the head that was given
or the decoration as uh
the rule form goes
but we didn't actually get what happened
to codemap it's in the queue it's in
Danny's queue it just wasn't
it is
m
M oh
I'm a little bit suspicious about that
name
okay let's not do it here yeah well so
if we talk about that again let's talk
about Association through at the same
time okay
the last two are probably going to be
slightly more complicated discussions
but select positions we started talking
about and we
Jose brought up this relationship that
position is to cases as counters to
cases
I said it oh Danny okay I'm sorry I'm I
don't know why I'm grabbing credit but
well I'm missing credit but
the idea was that having a
a test based version of positions is
potentially nice but if we're going to
go
into a test based version of that you
know do we want a select count also do
we want a bunch of Select related
functions you know I tried to do kind of
a deeper dive on the pattern based
functions and
you know for the pieces that we're
looking at I think
select position and counts are the the
primary ones you know we're not really
going to have a a select replace where
we're using a test based replacement
because
Replacements inherently are gonna yeah I
mean look we've had the code count by
hmm
family right and this is now a thing a
little bit like count by story
it counts spy right yeah I understand
yeah but this is another thing a little
bit like buy it's another adverb type
thing
right
I feel like if we
if we could come up with the right
adverb
I mean it's almost like positions by or
positioned by
count by
um
is it I mean I guess most yeah the buy
functions would have a test function
right right
it's a little weird buy isn't quite the
right but is there another adverb that
we can use there
that's an adverb I mean another
preposition
we can use the
well that would that would also handle
like giving select a level specification
we wouldn't actually need that because
you could have cases by or whatever we
would call it
that would essentially do that right
yes
let's think about what that preposition
could be okay I want to make one General
point and then we should wrap
um
you know as you all know I've been
working hard wrapping up this llm
function all these llm related functions
for 13 3. um
I do think that you know now that the
aliens have landed type thing we're you
know there's just an awful lot of llm
related functions and I kind of think
that we should pivot a little bit in
terms of these ild discussions to look
at
you know llm spin-off functions because
I think that they are you know they have
high potential in the short term
um and I guess we can talk about this
you know these things that I'm writing
about these things and what's going into
13 3 is happening fairly rapidly
probably by next week even we'll have
some more information about this but I I
kind of feel like I you know like I've
there's a you know the llm function
function is happening you know we know
how that's happening and I think there's
another idea of an llm block function
which um
we should be talking about uh so I hate
to blow things up but you know it's what
we get when the aliens have landed we
would need an llm blockchain of course
it also might be worth looking through
all the functions they haven't seen
which ones are would be useful as
utilities
in that ecosystem things that have to do
with templating
and what templating or NLP stuff right
because there might be some of those in
the ild list already that would be
helpful
and seriously it might be a good idea to
consider at least temporarily merging
this with another group since you have
people working on this that are not in
this group
sorry sorry I spiced for a second excuse
me looking something else could you say
it again please
it it would make sense to temporarily
merge ild with whatever group you
already have yes not every woman is in
this group no no I know I know but a lot
of the thinking that you guys are doing
here is going to apply you know
to these other kinds of functions except
that I think that they have more bang
for the buck right now because no no
argument but but some of the expertise
at the implementation level lies outside
this group and I agree I agree but I
mean one of the things that's happening
is because of llm function and the
related functions a lot of the structure
that has to be built Now does not depend
on detailed llm knowledge
that's that's yes I agree with you in
terms of these meetings but I'm also
saying that I think the good news is
that you know sort of the generic ild
function building operation can be
applied now to build out a bunch more
llm functions
all the more reason to marriage
expertise yeah no no it is it is
um all right sounds good okay I think we
should wrap up here and uh
talk to you soon